all anxiety begins with worrying your
negative thought Loop starts going this
is the baby the thoughts start to spin
your body and your nervous system take
notice anxiety is simply when worrying
starts to get lodged in your body it
begins with a worry then your body gets
agitated and when your body gets
agitated we make the mistake then of
letting the worries pick up oh my
stomach's on edge that must mean that
something bad is going to happen that
only ticks up the anxiety in your body
and at some point your body goes that's
it I'm getting her out of here panic
attack time when you start to attack the
worry Loop that's how you can slow down
the anxiety